congrats here we are again season three
of never have i ever uh you know there
were a lot of a lot of funny moments
this season but i want to start with
this love triangle because just when we
thought we had seen the last of this
like triangle between ben paxton and
davey you two are once again kind of
entangled in davey's love life i have to
figure out my boy situation stat what's
the alternative you just date two guys
until you move to india
so you're saying i should just have two
boyfriends definitely not
oh my god
i have two boyfriends who do you think
is best for davey are you two ben or
team paxton daryn we'll start with you
um
i'm team
he's right here what do i say
i know pressure bias aside
um you know
this always seems like a trap of a
question so i'm just gonna say i'm team
davey i hope she finds her happiness and
herself or whoever she wants now journey
i like to bring mine up into percentage
points so i'd give like
i don't know let's say 70 percent team
ben because i'm biased 20 team paxton
because i love darren and 10 team davey
because we all hope that she finds
self-love that's such a bad answer
that's such a bad answer i love it well
we do finally get to see your two
characters kind of forge a friendship
this season what was it like for you
guys to finally share some i don't know
more heartwarming scenes together
long awaited to be honest yeah um funny
jaren and i
when i first came in to like read for
the role or like test for the role of
pax he was there yeah and i thought he
was going for my role so i don't give
you i immediately was like
he must go
but we've grown uh really close over the
past couple years and i've always
appreciated his work and thought he was
amazing so doing scenes together has
been awesome yeah it's been really fun
especially too because we hadn't gotten
to do any scenes together and when we
did both ben and paxton would like kind
of look at each other like
would you talk to me why are you talking
to me so it was really cool to be able
to do a scene that was so heartwarming
and so complex and kabir the director
gave us some really great notes and i
know that when i saw it i was just like
wow it was so great and i know that some
people have come up to me that have seen
it and said that they've loved it it was
just awesome to get to work with you you
too man do you think we get to see more
of this bromance next season
i forget everything we just filmed to be
honest
because you guys already did you filmed
season four already yeah wow we did that
oh wow okay so you know some things all
right we we know some things and i think
that
ben and paxton's friendship is just
beginning and maybe there might be some
additions to that but uh you'll have to
tune into season four to find out what
really matters is jaren and darren are
friends in real life and the bromance
romance is here yeah i mean your name's
ryan so you're already halfway there
that's right
that's awesome
so darren paxton actually graduates this
season and he does get into college you
know can we see kind of his college
journey next season what's up next for
him yeah you you're in for a treat um i
feel like season four
we're talking about season four right
yeah no yeah
little t i won't as well
we go you're gonna i think i feel like
we go a lot more places there's a lot
more locations and like there's a lot
wider of a range of uh
of places you're gonna see in season
four which is which made a lot a lot of
fun to shoot and
it's definitely gonna be fun to watch
yeah
and jiren this season andy sandberg is
back as ben's narrator that must not get
old now you may be asking yourself why
is andy samberg narrating the story of
this particular boy well honestly his
dad's my lawyer and i owe him a favor
but ben seems like a good kid so happy
to do it is that the voice in your head
now andy sandberg yeah it's like my
voice in my head like 24 7. i also was
just such a huge sandberg fan as a kid
he was like definitely one of my idols i
think he's hilarious and so brilliant
and to be able to have him narrate my
character's thoughts season one i was
like mind blown in season three it was
just the exact same feeling it's just
it's like child like wonder so i'm so
appreciative that he was willing to do
it and i think he's hilarious
i feel like we need to get all the
narrators for the final season together
in one scene get like andy gigi adid
what do you guys think they should drop
a mixtape in the booth
that would be fire yeah right come on
uh jaron back to you let's talk about
the finale with davey because i mean
obviously that's a pretty good
cliffhanger there i don't want to give
it away but how would things change
well i think it's interesting especially
without giving too much away that ending
because we're not quite sure what ends
up happening right so i think it's gonna
be really exciting for fan reactions for
the end that end moment because really
you have no idea i think there's gonna
be definitely two sides that are like
yes and another side that's like we
don't know maybe it's a no maybe they
just chat i don't know so i think it's
going to be really exciting it kind of
really tease up like this next upcoming
final season and i feel like also the
stakes are high because we do know it's
ending after season four you know the
series is ending so darren knowing what
you know what can fans expect like what
was your reaction to what you guys
filmed
you know i don't think fans can ever
really know what to expect
their love triangle is always changing
shapes becoming that much more complex
and insane
um davey is still up to her same old
shenanigans if you will my mom wouldn't
let me come unless i brought one of her
friends loser kids so if you see an
indian dork come through that door let
me know i see an indian guy coming
through the door but he definitely does
not look like a dork
oh [ __ ]
jiren uh
are you satisfied with the way things
are kind of wrapping up for this series
i couldn't have like thought of anything
better i think that mindy and lang and
the rest of the writing team did an
unbelievable job i think that especially
for season four it's like the most
beautiful send-off it's like so
hilarious and so heartwarming and the
cast and crew put so much love and
effort into that final season and i
think that you can really feel that at
least we haven't seen it yet but like i
know when we were filming we would just
finish a scene and be like wow that was
awesome and it was just such a dream
being able to come to work every day
with people that we love and make a show
that's loved by so many so i don't i
just feel so grateful for that and i'm
so excited for everyone to see it